to Bali there you go our prime minister
countries war in Ukraine
barely 12 hours later
more than 80 Russian missiles rained
down on new Western Ukraine killing
civilians and destroying civilian
infrastructure
while other world leaders were working
together to tackle the greatest
challenges our people face
Putin was launching indiscriminate
attacks on civilians in Ukraine
in the wake of these attacks today we
held an urgent meeting of allies to
underscore our solidarity with Ukraine
and Poland
I also spoke to Polish president Duda
this morning to offer my wholehearted
support and assurance that the United
Kingdom stands steadfastly behind him
and his people at this worrying time
we should all be clear
none of this would be happening if it
weren't for Russia's invasion of Ukraine
this is the cruel and unrelenting
reality of Putin's War
as long as it goes on it poses a threat
to our security and that of our allies
and as long as it goes on it will
continue to devastate the global economy
two-thirds of G20 members are currently
experiencing inflation rates over seven
percent and the IMF predicts a third of
the world's economy will be in recession
this year or next
at a time when countries are tentatively
emerging from the ravages of the
covid-19 pandemic households across the
world have been hit by punishing price
Rises and are facing an uncertain future
when the G20 was established it was with
the acknowledgment that economic shocks
are inherently global
responding to them requires coordination
and cooperation between the world's
largest economies
we have come together over the years
despite our political differences in
recognition of the economic importance
of this forum
but this year in particular
as last night's events laid bare the
challenges we Face are utterly political
the persistent threat to our security
and global economic asphyxiation has
been driven by the actions of the one
man unwilling to be at this Summit
Vladimir Putin
there is not a single person in the
world who hasn't felt the impact of
Putin's War
Global Food Markets have been severely
disrupted by his attempts to choke off
Ukrainian grain Supply
there has been an eight-fold increase in
global Energy prices thanks to Russia
turning off their gas tax and the
economic aftershocks of Putin's casual
disregard for human life will Ripple
around the world for years to come
but in Indonesia this week the rest of
the G20 have refused to let Russia's
grandstanding and Hollow excuse making
undermine this important opportunity to
make life easier for our people
economic stability and confidence are at
the heart of the government's agenda
that means being a constructive and
reliable member to the International
Community using our influence to help
keep Global prices down and create the
conditions that will help the United
Kingdom and other Global economies
return to growth
at this Summit G20 Partners have come
together to strengthen our International
economic foundations making ambitious
commitments to help the most vulnerable
reduce Global Reliance on Russian fossil
fuels in favor of Greener more secure
Alternatives and drive a better future
where no country has the power to
devastate the global economy
I'd like to thank the Indonesian
president Jokowi for the role he has
played in hosting these discussions and
leading the G20 at this challenging time
tomorrow the chancellor will build on
these International foundations when he
makes the Autumn statement outlining his
plan to get the country on a positive
trajectory put the public finances on
the right footing and get debt falling
by promoting free markets forging strong
International relationships and
prioritizing our stability and security
we will build a global platform for the
United Kingdom to thrive
giving the people of our country the
certainty that they need
thank you
we'll take some questions from the Press
I think starting with Chris from the BBC
Chris over to you
control of this course
UK intelligence reports are saying what
what you've heard from them and if I may
what do you say to people today at
seeing this news who are deeply worried
that A Moment Like This even adopt this
particular incident could see the UK
drawn into a war with Russia
thank you Chris well this is something
that we discussed this morning at our
meeting of allies and I think what we
all agreed this morning was that it was
important for our teams to establish the
facts and that is exactly what is
happening as we speak there are teams on
the ground involving not just the polls
but also the ukrainians Americans and
others I think all of us want to get to
the bottom of what happened and it's
right that we let that process conclude
but to your second point and taking a
step back the reason we're even having
this conversation is because yesterday
Russia rained down over 80 missile
strikes on the ukrainians on civilians
on civilian infrastructure electricity
water and such like that's why we're
having this conversation and we can't
lose sight of that fact but we will get
to the bottom of what happened and
that's what the teams are doing as we
speak
uh Anushka ITV
when you were woken up at 5am this
told about this mess up
getting as far as Poland did it bring
home to you how quickly this wall could
yeah that's why one of the first things
I did this morning after receiving the
news was to call President Duda of
Poland uh Poland is a staunch Ally of
the United Kingdom and I wanted to give
him my personal reassurance and
commitment that we stand steadfast with
him and his people at this time were
there to help them with what they need
and to express my sympathies for the
loss of life that his country has
experienced but it does as I was saying
to Chris just put in Stark reality what
happened yesterday and I also spoke to
president zielinski earlier today with
prime minister Trudeau where he
described what was going on in his
country yesterday and it's awful to hear
as I said over 80 missile strikes
targeting civilian infrastructure with
the loss of civilian life that's what's
happening and by the way that was
happening at a time when the G20 was
gathered trying to find resolution to
some of the world's challenges and at
the same time Putin was raining down
indiscriminately that volume have
missile attacks I think it shows utter
contempt for the International
rules-based System and that's why it was
right that together with allies we
called out his illegal and barbaric War
strongly at the sessions that we had
Ryan where are you
it's Ryan Heights prime minister in one
interview yesterday you said illegal
migration was your number one Challenge
and the separate interview you said
inflation was your number one challenge
can I ask you ahead of the Autumn
statement where millions of people may
be worse off what is your number one
channel yeah well I my absolute number
one priority is making sure that we deal
with the economic situation that we face
at home
you know with more news of inflation
today it's the number one thing that's
on people's minds it's the thing that's
causing most anxiety opening up building
the emails come in with Rising prices
and that's why it's right that we grip
it and tomorrow the chancellor will set
out a plan that will enable us to do
that I think the first thing to say
about that is that it's a global
Challenge and I've been having lots of
conversations with my fellow leaders at
this Summit you heard what I said about
some of the statistics from the IMF
about the breadth of this challenge
across the world that's caused by the
legacy of covid it's caused by what
Putin is doing on Energy prices but that
doesn't make it any easier which is why
we need to take decisive action at home
to get our borrowing and debt on a
sustainable trajectory we'll do that
because that will help us tackle
inflation it will help us cut the cost
of things it will help us limit the
increase in mortgage rates and once we
have that stable Foundation which the
chance it'll provide tomorrow I'm
confident that we can move forward as a
country and we can look forward to a
brighter future and build on that
Foundation to provide jobs and
opportunity and prosperity around the
country but we need to get a group of
inflation first we need to have that
strong Foundation we're not alone as I
said in approaching the problem that way
actually the communique that was
released today by the G20 talked about
the need for long-term fiscal
sustainability deliberately in the
context of high inflation that we're
seeing around the world and that's why
it's right that we grip it um but yes
the next priority alongside that has
been illegal migration it's been the
thing that I've spent most of my time on
outside of preparing for the Autumn
statement and working with the
chancellor to do that I think that is a
priority for the British people and it's
something that they have my commitment I
will address you've seen that early
fruits of that work with the new deal we
have with the French and that came after
conversations I had with President
macron both on the phone and in person
when we were in Egypt together but
that's not the end that's the Start of
Greater cooperation and it's just one of
a suite of measures that we will have to
take to reduce the number of illegal
migrants coming to the UK but I'm
determined to do that and I'm sure that
we can deliver it over time
Ben well there you are
thank you prime minister two quick ones
one on the Autumn statement
um it's going to get a lot tougher for a
lot of people in the country with what's
coming tomorrow tax Rises spending cuts
can you just explain to the British
public why they need to accept what's
coming and secondly you talk to Joe
Biden today sounds like you didn't
explicitly talk about a U.S free trade
deal have you given up hopes for the U.S
free trade there before the next
election
great I think what
you know what I'd say to people watching
at home is we were just discussing
actually to Ryan's question what's
people's number one anxiety at the
moment it's the rising cost of things
it's inflation that's what's eating into
people's living standards and the chance
of a rightly described it as Insidious
it makes people poorer that's what
inflation does and it's the enemy that
we need to face down and I want to make
sure that we do that and we do it as
quickly as possible I want to limit the
increase in mortgage rates because
that's also causing anxiety for millions
of homeowners across the UK and given
that we're facing these global economic
shocks we are going to have to take some
difficult decisions at home to protect
ourselves against those and to start
getting a grip of inflation reducing it
and limiting the increase in mortgage
rates so that's why we're doing what
we're going to have to do tomorrow but
what I would also say to people they've
kind of got a glimpse over the summer of
what can happen if we don't get these
things right and we want to make sure
that we do and we have stability and
confidence in the United Kingdom's
economy but also I want to tell people
that the decisions that we'll be making
tomorrow will be based on fairness
they'll be based on compassion and I am
confident that when people see the set
of decisions in the round when the
chancellor is delivered his statement
that they will see that we have strived
incredibly hard to deliver fairness to
deliver compassion and put the UK on a
positive economic trajectory you know
that's what I'm here to do and that's
why I'm confident they will deliver on
trade we have a very good conversation
with President Biden on a range of
things you know we didn't discuss the
trade deal in particular but we did
discuss our economic partnership and
both of us acknowledge the fact that
actually we are the United States is our
single largest trading partner and
there's a range of economic cooperation
that is happening and can continue to
happen in the future we talk about
energy for example and you know how we
can work together to improve energy
security at a time when we're all
wanting to have more of that at home and
so I I'm filled with optimism about our
ability to do more trade with the us to
do in our economic relationship but I
said that that can happen in lots of
different ways and you'll see that over
the coming months and years I'm sure
Seb from the Ft well there you are so hi
thank you prime minister
um the UK's economic World seem to be
particularly acute compared to some of
its neighbors and like-minded countries
do you accept that brexit in any way is
a contributive factor to those issues
and linked to that the former
environment secretary George Eustis has
said the UK's trade deal with Australia
is essentially a dud that does we gave
far too much away for far too little
will you be looking to renegotiate that
and how do we avoid that in the future
I think when you're thinking about what
the UK's economic situation is I'd point
you back to the comments and the
statistics that I've made in my opening
my opening remarks is two-thirds of the
global economy or G20 members seeing
inflation rates above seven percent at
the moment the IMF thinks a third of the
global economy either is or will be in
recession that is the global context
that's what's dominated the
conversations that I've been having here
and and we know why that is it's the
legacy of covid and it's uh of course
what Putin is doing that is driving up
energy and indeed food prices and you
talk to some of my colleagues from
Africa and what they're grappling with
they're very cognizant of that so that
that's the global economic context and I
think that is what's dominating what's
happening um you know every country is
going to have idiosyncratic things but
those are the overwhelming dominating
factors that are leading to the economic
challenge that we're facing at the
moment now with regard to Australia look
every trade deal has you know there's
give and take on both sides you know
what I say to people about the Australia
trade deal it's gonna make it easier for
young young Brits to and Australians to
go and and work and visit each other's
countries which is positive thing it's
going to reduce the prices of Australian
Goods in the UK and it's also going to
sport over 3 million British jobs which
are engaged in exporting to Australia
but what I've said on trade deals more
generally is that my Approach will be
one where we don't sacrifice quality for
Speed I want to take the time to get
trade deals right make sure that they
work for the UK I'm confident that we
can do that and indeed I've been having
conversations with other leaders here
about deeping our trade Partnerships
particularly in the indo-pacific region
with Australia with Japan and with
Canada the cptpp arrangement I've spoken
to all those leaders about uh our plans
to join back trade uh free trade area
which are exciting and I'll be doing
that after I leave here as well as well
as the trade deal with India which you
know we remain committed to but we need
to make sure we get these things right
and that that's what I will do brilliant
and I think we have one last question
from the international press uh Laura
suffe where are you from Compass is that
right yes thank you prime minister
my question is like over the recent
increase in geopolitical tensions how is
the UK going to work together with all
of your G20 peers to implement today's
communique thank you thank you uh it was
an excellent question to end on I you
know I think probably there may have
been people who came into this Summit
with some skepticism about what was
possible and I just think actually I'll
start by paying enormous tribute to
president Jokowi for his leadership in
what have not been easy circumstances
but the communique that was released
today is substantive it's comprehensive
it's action oriented and it was by no
means assured and I think the president
and his team deserve enormous praise
before the leadership that they've
demonstrated over the year but
especially over the past few days but
your question rightly is about well how
do we how do we make sure that that's a
reality well I think you saw it I think
you saw the Spirit of cooperation on
display in the meetings that we had uh
there was a strong desire to both
condemn Putin for the illegal war in
Ukraine and expressed solidarity with
the ukrainians president zielinski I
think powerfully addressed the sessions
but also to work together on all the
other challenges that we Face the global
economy making sure that we combat
inflation together making sure that we
transition to a Greener more secure
Energy Future or indeed helping the most
vulnerable when it comes to food and
again credit to the president of Turkey
and the United Nations Secretary General
for their work on the Black Sea grain
deal where I think there's strong
alignment amongst colleagues to make
sure that we extend that deal that we
continue to have the supply not just the
food but a fertilizer and ensure that
Russia doesn't stop that from happening
because there are many countries that
are suffering two-thirds of the wheat
from Ukraine goes to developing
countries it's important that we
maintain that flow so I think those are
some of the things coming out of this
Summit that I want to make sure we go
and focus on and deliver for people but
what I'd also say is I think there's
excitement about India taking the Baton
I think Prime Minister Modi made an
excellent speech at the close of the
summit and there's a lot of positivity
about this positive about all the
positive things that have come up out of
this Summit being carried on into
India's presidency and people are
looking forward to supporting India in
that and and we certainly will play our
part in the United Kingdom to make sure
that we do that perfect thank you all
very much
our prime minister speaking at the G20
Summit in Bali in Indonesia
um a couple of body swerves in there but
he did talk about the situation in
Poland overnight after a missile
originally thought to be Russia now does
appear to be Ukrainian killed two people
he said if Russia hadn't invaded
um Ukraine then the situation would not
have been as it is this morning also
talked about the cost of living crisis
here in the United Kingdom and the fact
that inflation is now up to 11.1 hitting
a 41 year high blamed all sorts of
things
um it was asked about brexit tomorrow is
here bodies were that one didn't he did
quite a few words you swerved who might
be responsible for the missile which hit
a Polish a village killing two people he
just said that the UK would be
supporting the investigation and we know
that British sunak and Justin the
Canadian Prime Minister held a joint
call with President zielinski this
morning he said the focus must be the
bombardment that the ukrainians are
under he also talked a bit about
tomorrow's Autumn statement he'll be
flying back of course today in order to
see the chance to deliver that he said
inflation is the enemy that we face and
it will be the Chancellor's job to do
all he can to try and tackle it as it
reaches new highs wouldn't get into
whether uh brexit had been the source of
uh knocks to the economy he did seem to
roll the pitch for saying that all
countries are experiencing inflation he
pointed out that two-thirds of G7
members are experiencing inflation over
seven percent but Britain is one of the
highest I think it's the highest behind
Italy so of course questions about how
much his predecessor was responsible for
that and on the U.S trade deal so they
didn't get around to discussing it but
when asked a question about whether Liz
truss had mismanaged the Australia trade
deal which is the accusation being made
by one of her former cabinet colleagues
he said he will prioritize quality over
speed so perhaps that one's being kicked
into the long grass okay for now
tomorrow thanks very much indeed
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock so the
headlines there are still trying to
establish the facts behind missiles
Landing in Poland we've seen these
images from overnight haven't we were
two people
um sadly have lost their lives as